I just changed the
structure my brain--
or broke something up there.
We should have an ambulance
standing by, guys.
Anthony here for D News.
And your brain is adapting
and changing all the time
based on everything you do.
A new study from
Imperial College London
shows that ballet dancers'
brain structures actually
change to keep them
from getting dizzy.
They just suppress the
signal from the inner ear
that tells them to
get disoriented.
Just, nope, not needed.
Filter that information, please.
But it's not just a
switch or a filters.
The bits of the
cerebral cortex that
process those signals
actually shrink.
They get out of the way to allow
other bits to get stronger.
This is neuroplasticity,
and is the jam.
It's a fairly new
idea, even though it
was proposed in 1890
by William James.
Up until the 1960s,
everyone pretty much
thought that once
childhood was over,
your brain just froze,
stopped developing.
Not only is that
false-- the extent
to which your brain
can change is crazy.
A study of London
cab drivers actually
found that they have more
fully developed hippocampuses
than most people.
That's the part of
the brain associated
with space and memory.
Animals that hide food for
the winter and have to find it
later have more fully developed
hippocampuses than animals that
don't.
And years of having to know
their way around all 25,000
streets of London made the cab
drivers' brains restructure
to become good at it.
Studies of the brains
of high-level athletes
have showed that having
to focus on precision
and constantly integrate
feedback into their routine
actually thickens the outermost
layers of their brains.
Scientists can
actually tell how long
somebody has been intensely
practicing a sport by how thick
those layers are.
But it doesn't take years
of practiced routine
to make this stuff happen.
Your brain is insanely adaptive,
even in the short-term--
even if you just think
about changing it.
A Harvard study a few years
back gave two groups of people
a couple days of piano lessons.
Then one group practiced
for another five days
and the other group imagined
practicing for five days.
They just mentally
went through the steps
of playing the
song in their head.
And after scanning
everyone's brains,
they found that the motor
cortexes of both groups
expanded just as much, at
least for the first few days.
Now, on the other hand,
neuroplasticity could
be part of why habits
can be so hard to break,
and might also have
a hand in addiction.
Mice given cocaine just once
grew new brain circuitry
within two hours.
They adapted quickly
to love the drug
and to seek out the environment
where it was given to them.
But it also means
that if you need
to change a habit that
seems impossible to kick,
you might still be
able to strengthen
the parts of your brain
you need to get rid of it.
A study of musicians'
brains show
that they have highly
developed frontal lobes
and are more likely to be
calmer and open-minded.
So if you have anger or
defensiveness issues,
you could potentially
take up an instrument
to help train
yourself out of them.
Basically, your brain
becomes the brain
you make it through
what you do every day.
You can train it just like
any other part of your body.
Now I just need to know
which part of my brain
hits the snooze button too
many times in the morning.
What would you like to
train your brain to do?
Let me know down in the comments
and subscribe for more D News.